so the infinite game is not the absence
of finite games
it is the context within which those
finite games exist
right
and
and it's and it's also understanding the
game you're in at the time you're in the
game so for example if it's a new
business pitch
that's finite there is a beginning
middle and end there is someone who'll
be declared the winner and there's a
group that will be declared the losers
and then the game ends
right the pitch is over
now once you have the relationship now
it should be more infinite minded so you
convert like winning an election
is finite governance is infinite
um and we see what happens in governance
when they they're trying to win
when there should be governing right it
hurts the whole system
so um we overuse things like sports
analogies
in business
um which is always a finite game
um and i think a better analogy to use
is is lifestyle
and and
again there's nothing wrong with
uh metrics and goals they're very
important human beings need
to count things we're we're visually
driven animals we're tangibly driven
animals you can't run a marathon without
mile markers it's actually unnerving
right
and but we have to remember that those
metrics are measures of speed and
distance how fast are we going how far
have we gone but they're not they don't
constitute the end of the game
they're just mile markers right
and so
a better way to think of business is
like thinking i want to be a healthy
person that lives a healthy lifestyle
okay what are all the things you need to
do you need to eat well you need to
sleep you need to nurse your personal
relationships you need to exercise
there's probably a list of 30 other
things what do you need to build a great
business you need marketing you need
sales you need great hr you need to oh
my god the list is exhaustive you can't
do all those things great all the time
just like you can't do all those things
great in our lives all the time it's a
pursuit
and the more we have help and the more
we have a gym buddy the more likely we
are to be better at those things
and you can
set arbitrary goals and this is most of
business when somebody says we're going
to hit this number on this date
somebody just made that up
like
literally right in fact sometimes goes i
think we can do better and you're like
you're right and here's the new goal you
know
and it's usually 12 months because
that's when we pay taxes
but there's that's arbitrary too
so if you're trying to lose x amount of
weight by x date arbitrary number
arbitrary date totally just like
business
and what do you do you start driving
towards it
and you measure every day you stand on
the scale every morning and some days
you feel good some days you feel like
you're falling behind
and let's say you hit that goal you're
you're elated
and then what yeah well the problem is
the game's not over you have to keep
exercising for the rest of your life
just because you hit a goal means
nothing and and can i also say how did
you get to that and how did you get to
the goal and that i think is even more
important which is what happens if you
miss the goal
well you're probably way healthier now
than you were when you started and you
just picked the wrong number on the
wrong date you're easily going to hit
your goal in 14 months you can see the
trend data right and i think that's the
thing that's missing
when we when we play the game of
business which is the absolutes are
finite but it's the trend it's how we
get somewhere because you know this
as well as everybody in this room which
is if i have two teams
and i simply bonus you by one factor and
one factor alone which is did you hit
the number on the date
right
you know
you can have a leader who drops the
price at the last minute runs a bunch of
promotions begs borrows steals stabs
people in the back steals information
they hit the number on the date we treat
them like a hero we give them a bonus
and it sends a message to the rest of
the company we don't care how you get
your numbers as long as you get your
numbers well over the course of time
that has an impact on your culture
versus
the
team that has an amazing nobody quits
nobody's fired morale is high
like and you see the trend data is
beautiful it's not this roller coaster
it's just beautiful line
and they just missed the number on the
date
and we give that team nothing
as opposed to saying you're going to hit
your goal you guys have been doing well
and we do bonus that team
and i think it's very important to
consider how we got there are you
obeying our values as you work and
what's the trend
hit on that obeying the values getting
into culture you said it earlier the
decline of trust yeah with the infinite
game versus the finding hit that because
i think that's a beautiful message
so when we when we're when we driven
again if you're in a finite game play by
finite rules
but the context has to be infinite and
this is where vision and mission comes
in i call it the just cause which is all
of those finite wins are for what are
they to make a group of a small group of
people much wealthier
is that is that is what's the goal of
hitting those so you can brag you're
number one based on the metrics that you
chose
you know market share revenues i mean
who knows number of offices you get to
pick
um
have you ever noticed that every airline
is number one never noticed that
um
and to understand that these these these
goals that we're trying to hit they
serve a higher purpose
i i had the opportunity to visit um
quantico marine base
uh uh in virginia and
uh this is where they select their
officers
um and
one of the things they run them through
is something called the lrc which is the
leadership reaction course which is 20
mini obstacle courses they're basically
problem solving courses like you have to
get all your men and material over this
little water hazard that's what the
marines call a pond
uh
uh
you know
within a certain time frame with three
planks of wood of different size stuff
like that right
and
when i was watching them do it
i'm standing next to the drill
instructor and you know they're grading
the marines to see their leadership
qualities and nowhere on the page does
it say that made it they made it to the
other side mission success was not on
the sheet
and i said
how come you don't have like if they
made it to the side on the on the page
like it's not even a check box
and the drill instructor said
we understand that good leaders
sometimes suffer mission failure
and bad leaders sometimes enjoy mission
success
he said
what we're looking for are the qualities
that make someone a good leader and if
we select people that
that exhibit the qualities of good
leadership we know over the course of
time they will enjoy more success than
not maybe i'm going the wrong direction
here but we're such a metric focused
group what kind of metrics can you use
the infinite game so the traditional
metrics are fine um uh there's nothing
wrong with the traditional metrics um
um
but uh there there are other metrics
that are missing
um like i said i like i like uh
trend data in the infinite game rather
than absolutes
i like to know
like okay we missed our numbers this
month that's okay how have they been
like is it is it an anomaly is it a blip
like should we panic i mean there was a
great story just a few years ago
um
from ibm where they missed their sales
numbers and uh
the ceo
jim mccaffrey came out and made a video
and then sent this video out to the
whole company which is humiliating for
the sales team and
by the way it was the first time they'd
missed their numbers in something like
68 quarters
the first time ever and her reaction was
to dump on a group of people and destroy
morale it could have been a blip maybe
it was something in the marketplace
maybe it had nothing to do with ibm
maybe it was something because their
processes are that needed fixing and so
i mean that's my point which is when
we're so obsessed with those numbers
that we literally fail to recognize that
this has been our trend data for 68
quarters blip it's myopic it's classic
yeah close judgment so i think i think
the traditional metrics are okay if we
take a broad view
my
hope is that we develop new metrics to
live alongside
the analogy i'll give is you know um you
know most of us the person we end up
with for the rest of our lives you know
we find them physically attractive
great but that's not enough we want to
know the depth of the kind of person
they are
and metrics are the same in business
which is you know the the traditional
metrics are the easy things to measure
like physical attractiveness is the easy
thing to see
and i think that we need new metrics in
business not to replace but to just
offer some balance so do we have good
metrics of
of
the health of our culture do we have
good metrics of the health of our
leaders do we have good metrics of the
health of our of our people um
you know that goes beyond the the the
annual pulse survey